i'm a
research assistant at the german police
university in munster which is
placed in beautiful notre dame with farm
um yeah i was very much amazed how much
um
machine learning which is such a fancy
fancy word everyone uses these days as
if it was something completely different
and something completely new i was
amazed how much this had actually um to
do with concepts i already knew back
from my statistical courses from
university
and
how well andrew also explained this how
much this is all basically just
just based upon regression modeling and
and
ordinary statistical skills
of course once i had the algorithms
ready and and my scripts are already in
my in my
um
on my desktop here um i from time to
time always apply these models and
try to see if it makes a difference and
performance and yeah
just test all these different concepts
against each other and just pick the one
that that provides the best results in
the end
now that i've completed these courses
i'm being taking much more serious also
on on
providing
expertise knowledge and making
suggestions on
how to set up the algorithms how to do
the feature engineering
what to look out for what to actually
test
how this can can feed back into
fundamental theoretical research and
theory building
the term might sound intimidating but
it's just not if you have a little bit
of background in statistical computing
it's not that intimidating at all it's
just a lot of fun actually
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you